Chris and I have been asked to present
two awards to the incredibly talented
people responsible for stirring our
imagination through the use of sound
sound adds dimension to film whether it
be simple and naturalistic or terrifying
and out of this world
first up here the nominees for
achievement and sound editing
you
and the Oscar goes to Mad Max fury road
this is the first
nomination for David White the first win
and fourth nomination for mark man
who is previously nominated for Star
Trek for the voyage home Aladdin and the
Fifth Element
[ __ ] mad Max's let's head for
thousands of years we've been telling
stories in the dark around a flickering
light whether a campfire or a projector
David and I do it with sound George
Miller would tell us Mad Max is a film
we see with our ears a new sound could
tell my story but nothing quite like
this sound artists are storytellers
thank you George
I hope to see you around the next
campfire yeah I'm so proud so proud to
work on this loud loud loud film that
actually had silence in it so good to
work with this guy and I'm proud to
represent all my Australian colleagues
yeah